you've done the gathering of the
juggalos right oh my god yes shout out
to the
whoop whoop
what was that my boy ouija what was that
like which is [ __ ] insane first time
i ever went there right i told the story
before so i'll tell some like other dude
so first time we pulled in there's this
like big-ass girl naked as [ __ ] just
sitting on a dude's face riding his face
like just
[ __ ] all on his [ __ ] mustache like
how big
yeah
it's hard to measure girls like what 250
nice little [ __ ]
little [ __ ] what's her name goddamn
tammy
god damn time he was going to pull into
the gathering of the juggalos and
there's a fat white woman right in the
face and some dude's just sitting there
yeah they look like a kitten with a can
of tuna and [ __ ]
so yeah so yeah so we saw that
and then there was like this drug bridge
or like where or oh no there was a raw
dog tent where you go in there and [ __ ]
the girl with no rubber
and like yeah the raw dog tent with now
this is before they change their whole
[ __ ] wait wait mind you i've never been
this is yo shout out to all the juggalos
out there man you guys showed me so much
love i'm just not going front and act
like i knew what the [ __ ] was going on
wait wait wait wait the raw dog tent
um so what is like there's one girl
who's just in there getting [ __ ] wrong
that's what i heard i never obviously
stepped into the raw dog tent so it's
just a [ __ ] who's just
yeah like you've got a [ __ ] with no
rubber and you you know you go in there
and just dog her out everybody's coming
in there
you know it's the raw dog tent
going in raw dog and there's a drug
bridge
yo [ __ ] was crazy back there i remember
seeing the ghetto boys perform there you
know it's my favorite group of all time
like dude i told you i met my dean
tonight oh my god so like ghetto boys my
do i seen ghetto boys perform there but
these [ __ ] juggalo ass white boys
they have no idea they had some but yeah
not like man i i i hate it i wanted to
go up there man this [ __ ]
ghetto boy
but they ain't giving [ __ ] about me
either you're upset so i'm watching this
[ __ ] but yeah that [ __ ] is wow dude
that's just crazy raw dog tent and the
drug bridge is like a bridge that you
could just go like you know yeah
i don't know get your heroin get your
meth right and but so this is how
i'm sure everyone was on meth well
that's how tricky that [ __ ] is because i
could talk about it and like a million
these [ __ ] diss me so juggalos
i love you i don't know about raw dog
tent
or all that i've heard and i've also
seen and y'all [ __ ] are crazy i
will say this though
at my parents house
my mom and dad's house they have on
their cable they have the juggalo
channel on their what's it roku there's
a juggalo channel yes and they have the
[ __ ] gathering and i got to saw and i
was like oh [ __ ] i know them yo you get
to see like them like dancing and [ __ ]
and twerking and [ __ ] yeah on a juggalo
channel on [ __ ] roku with all due
respect
you gotta watch this tonight
nah i'm good man dude you you might like
it i always say that icp
fans
with all due respect
are the ugliest [ __ ] fans in
all the hip-hop
see this why this motherfucker's gonna
get me in trouble no i'm not i'm just
saying i've been to some icp shows
and them juggalettes
they're just not the ones you know what
i'm saying i mean you know what's crazy
is like i heard all these like rumors it
looked like my aunts what's [ __ ] up is
when you
you're stupid is that what's [ __ ] up
is when you go on stage like man you
don't know they might they're supposed
to throw like bottle rockets at you they
hit you with [ __ ] if they don't like you
blah blah like when you even when
they're happy even when they like your
song like
it sounds like they're booing and [ __ ]
and like it's it's [ __ ] it's a crazy
experience and now there's like 45 year
old
teachers in high school yeah with
hatchet man tattoos that they got when
they were 18. i mean let's not get me
wrong i mean the nudity is cool i mean
there's a lot of oblong titties and a
lot there's a lot of long titties
there's a lot of long pills a lot of
stretch marks with some [ __ ] lime
green on them [ __ ] you know
congratulations you know like you go to
a fortune you go to a 420 show and it
smells like weed i feel like if you went
to the gathering of the juggalos it
would smell like meth smoke
no
it really has a mess being blown in the
air no no it really doesn't it really
does it smells like like fago like nbo
soda and feet
no no no no no i ain't gonna do them
like that no i will now i'm backstage to
be honest i go on there and i just hope
that i don't get hit with none
straight up i'm like just show them love
and like yo but i did tour with icp i
toured with them 2019
and uh so that was i mean you know
what's crazy is i'd love to interview
those guys because i feel like
while i think that their fans are
interesting to me
uh aesthetically
not the most pleasing uh but
i respect their
i feel like they're truly
pioneers
in this rap [ __ ] and i mean that with
all due respect they literally showed
everyone the way and i and like
and that's to say like everyone like the
merch game the indie game like they were
the first [ __ ] to really
dive in and monetize their fan base in a
way that no one else was doing oh man so
like it was salute to them
icp are legends i never was into their
[ __ ] like my cousin used to bump the
great malenco all the time and uh my
other cousin used to work for the
cottonmouth king so i would always go to
congress
but like
you know they they
they mastered monetizing their fan base
and so many people use their blueprint
to this day